en el vídeo pasado aprendiste cuando ya
te conté no sé si si ya no lo aprendiste
pero una importante conté te conté que
la fuerza que un campo magnético ejercía
sobre una carga en movimiento era igual
a la magnitud de la carga multiplicada
por el producto cruz de la velocidad con
el campo magnético va además de esto
platicamos acerca de las unidades del
campo magnético y dijimos que eran los
teclas donde un tesla estaba dado por
newton por segundo dividido entre colom
por metro vale esta expresión de acá lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
resolver un problema pues para entender
un poquito más estas fórmulas y fijar un
poco más las ideas este problema lo
saqué de un libro de cálculo y dice así
dice imaginemos que tenemos un campo
magnético cuya dirección es hacia afuera
del libro bueno esto no es un libro este
es un vídeo entonces puedes imaginarte
que este campo magnético está apuntando
hacia ti estas bolitas que estoy
pintando justo son vectores que tú estás
viendo desde allá arriba vale
tenemos citas y el puntito es únicamente
pues el extremo del vector que tú puedes
ver va entonces el campo apunta hacia ti
además de esto sabemos que la magnitud
de este campo de este campo es igual a
0.5 teslas vale bueno resulta que una
partícula va a entrar en este campo
magnético entonces esa partícula va a
ser un protón ese de ahí es un protón y
va a empezar o bueno se va a estar
moviendo con una velocidad
con una velocidad de magnitud 6
por 10 a 7 metros metros sobre segundo
vale esta velocidad de acá en realidad
es muy alta es como un quinto de la
velocidad de la luz siendo así muy
estrictos con la física actual
tendríamos que meter cosas relativistas
porque este es casi una velocidad
relativista entonces hay que ver y bueno
que la masa del protón se afecta o no se
afecta pero no vamos a ser tan estrictos
este es un problema sencillo entonces
vamos a pensar que la alteración de la
masa es despreciable que en verdad no
nos importa vale bueno entonces la
pregunta es cuál es la magnitud y la
dirección de la fuerza que ejerce este
campo magnético en este protón que se
está moviendo va bueno pues vamos parte
por parte vamos a empezar con la
magnitud déjame déjame poner por acá la
fórmula para acordarnos entonces la
magnitud de la fuerza la magnitud de la
fuerza está dada por la carga
multiplicada por la magnitud de la
velocidad multiplicada por la magnitud
del campo magnético por el seno de teta
esto lo platicamos en el vídeo pasado y
tenía que ver con la definición de
producto cruz vale bueno entonces vamos
a poner cosa por cosa aquí tenemos que
poner pues la carga de un protón porque
un protón tiene cierta carga la verdad
ahorita no me acuerdo de eso pero no hay
que preocuparnos eso lo tengo ahí
guardado en la calculadora son numeritos
que plus igual y no vale tanto la pena
aprenderse sí los puedes tener a tu
disposición entonces aquí tenemos la
magnitud del protón que ahorita vemos
cuánto es vamos a dejarle como como q de
no va a poner q dp la magnitud de la
carga de un protón y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por la magnitud de la
velocidad 6 por 10 a la 7 metros sobre
segundo ahorita no lo voy a poner por la
magnitud del campo magnético 0.5 por el
seno del ángulo entre la velocidad y el
campo en vez de ponerlo vamos a pensar
le tantito a ver si podemos sacar esto
rápido ve cuál sería el ángulo entre
esta de acá entre la velocidad que tiene
el protón y el campo magnético pues ve o
sea cualquier
quiere este vector que esté en este
plano que es la pantalla pues va a ser
perpendicular a este campo de acá porque
este campo está apuntando hacia afuera
está apuntando hacia ti entonces todos
los vectores de este plano pues son
perpendiculares a estos vectores que son
los del campo magnético y por lo tanto
la velocidad esta velocidad va a ser
perpendicular justo a pues cualquiera de
estos vectores es perpendicular al campo
bueno está muy padre verdad entonces ya
sabemos que el ángulo entre entre el
campo y la velocidad es de 90 grados o
de pi medio si eres más fan de los de
los radiales pero bueno cuánto sería el
seno de 90 grados o de pi medios pues es
simplemente uno va entonces este seno de
teta es igual a 1 entonces ya tenemos
todo para calcular deja de poner igual a
y aquí voy a sacar la calculadora están
acá instalada de 83 vamos a encenderla y
mira lo que te contaba es esto aquí en
la variable p le puse alfa
guarde la carga la carga de un protón
que es 1.6 por 10 a la menos 19 este es
un 10 al menos 19 aquí tenemos un -19
entonces vamos a hacer la operación
necesito llamar a esta variable p
y eso multiplicarlo por 6 por 10 a la 7
tiene un botón de 10 a la 10 a las 7
cerramos paréntesis y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por 0.5 entonces exacto ok
pero entero y me queda 4.8 por 10 a la
menos 12 bueno vamos a ponerlo por acá
4.8 por 10 a la menos 12 ojo aquí es
fuerza entonces estoy acá serían newtons
hasta el final ponemos newtons vale
bueno esto está súper bien ya tenemos la
magnitud de la fuerza pero todavía nos
falta su dirección cómo le hacemos para
determinar la dirección pues ahora sí
vamos a utilizar la regla de la mano
derecha y como se le hacía para eso pues
déjame pintar una mano voy a agarrar
este color
manu supongo entonces voy a poner por
aquí
la muñeca ahí tenemos la muñeca va
entonces cómo se hace para utilizar la
regla de la mano derecha pues este
primer vector que está en el producto
cruz va a corresponder con el dedo
índice entonces voy a poner aquí el dedo
índice porque porque la velocidad está
yendo hacia allá hacia allá va la
velocidad va ahora este segundo
corresponde con el dedo medio dejan con
el aquí y de dedo índice aquí m de dedo
medio entonces ahora tengo que apuntar a
hacer que mi dedo medio de la mano
derecha apunte hacia afuera lo voy a
pintar así déjame ponerlo un poco más
bonito así va entonces imagínate que
está apuntando hacia ti quién le puedes
poner el puntito para acordarte que está
apuntando hacia ti eso de ahí es ve está
aquí es completa estoy aquí es con
flechita este es el campo magnético deja
de pintar los otros dos dedos más o
menos algo así está mi otro dedo el
anular es el dedo pequeño por acá viene
la mano bueno pero lo importante lo
importante para saber hacia dónde va el
producto cruz y por tanto la fuerza es
ver hacia dónde apunta el pulgar
y el pulgar cuando pones la mano así
apunta hacia abajo si lo ves hasta el
pulgar más o menos así verdad y bueno
soy muy bueno para dibujar manos pero
creo que más o menos se ve se ve la idea
entonces hacia allá apunta a la
velocidad hacia ti apunta de ave que es
el campo vectorial y por lo tanto la
fuerza bueno el producto cruz pero
también la fuerza va a apuntar hacia
abajo hacia abajo en este plano que es
la pantalla entonces qué le sucede a
esta partícula de por acá bueno pues ya
sabemos que la fuerza que está
ofreciendo el campo magnético la hace ir
hacia acá hacia abajo entonces después
pues ya no va está moviéndose hacia la
derecha verdad ahora va a estar como por
aquí y su velocidad va a estar como por
allá pero qué sucede en este momento
ahora en este momento también tenemos
la fuerza ejercida es perpendicular a la
velocidad a la nueva velocidad entonces
ahora la partícula va a jalarse tantito
para acá entonces qué sucede a final de
cuentas pues resulta que la partícula va
a ir describiendo un círculo y te puedes
acordar de esto por lo que hemos
platicado de de fuerzas centrípetas y de
cosas por el estilo cuando tenemos una
fuerza perpendicular al movimiento
entonces se describe un círculo muy bien
entonces ya encontramos la magnitud ya
encontramos la dirección y vimos una
pequeña cosa que pasa en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a encontrar el radio de este
círculo de acá pero pues antes de paz
bueno o sea nada más como conclusión de
este vídeo quiero quiero que te quedes
pensando en alguna cosa y que es algo un
poco raro osea fíjate como que no
dependió para nada de la masa de nuestro
protón verdad en realidad todo está dado
pues nada más como de la carga y de la
velocidad de hecho eso es rarísimo de la
carga no tanto pero el hecho de que el
campo magnético sepa a qué velocidad te
estás moviendo como
como tiene algo muy raro por ahí como le
hace el campo magnético para saber qué
tan rápido eres bueno está bien lo voy a
dejar hasta aquí para que lo pienses
tantito y nos vemos en el próximo vídeo
para determinar este radio hasta la
próxima